a radio message
from taiwan warned approaching chinese
warplanes to turn around
you've entered our air defense
identification zone an air force
official
said leave immediately
such incursions are an increasingly
familiar routine
but the size of the chinese show of
strength in late
january 2021 was unusually
said the drills were designed to send a
warning to anyone seeking
independence for taiwan which is
regarded by china
as a breakaway province though the
island's democratically elected
government
has a close security relationship with
the united states
that is potentially a very dangerous
flash point
and it's a more dangerous flash point
today than it was two or three years ago
the aerial action around taiwan also
coincided with the deployment of a
powerful u.s aircraft carrier group
into the south china sea
the use of military power such as the
deployment of warplanes or ships
close to or even inside the airspace or
territorial waters of an opponent
is one of the most openly aggressive
tools states can use against each other
in the gray zone
it raises the risk of a miscalculation
or accident
that could ignite a real war
the status of taiwan is one of an array
of frictions between
china's ruling communist party and the
united states
think the pro-democracy movement in hong
kong
china's uighur muslim minority in
xinjiang province
for suspicion around the origin of the
coronavirus pandemic
it's creating a global battle of values
democracy
against authoritarianism and it's being
fought
with an array of covert weapons from
cyber attacks and information operations
to economic coercion
even something called lawfare
allegations of such behavior
are made and denied by both sides which
of course
is to be expected in the gray zone
[Music]
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor at sky news
and you're listening to my podcast into
the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
in this episode we look at how tensions
between an
increasingly confident china and its
democratic rivals
are playing out in the gray zone in
particular
we explore beijing's crackdown on
pro-democracy activists in hong kong
and ask what that might mean for the
future of another key territory
the democratically governed island of
[Music]
taiwan
[Music]
every every now and again an email
address that looks remarkably
like mine always clearly impersonating
me sends out
press releases or information to various
people
claiming to be from me and claiming that
i have agreed something or done
something or whatever it happens to be
tom tuggenhart is a conservative mp and
chair
of the uk parliament's foreign affairs
committee
he's describing what he alleges our
attempts
originating from china to discredit him
by sending out messages from phony email
accounts purporting to be his
you know i've spoken to the internet
providers who
host these mail sites and
each time they've told me pretty clearly
where the email address was registered
um and um as they take it down
point out that you know this is quite
clearly a set up
by uh people within mainland china um
and you know it's pretty pathetic it's
it's not the most sophisticated of hacks
um but it's
it's another attempt to intimidate and
while i don't
feel even slightly threatened by them if
i were
a hong konger or somebody from mainland
china
who still had family in in mainland
china or
anywhere that china could influence i
may well feel very differently about it
i asked the chinese embassy in the uk
about the allegation
they responded by questioning whether mr
tukenhart
had quote verified the authenticity of
his claim
mr touganhart has perhaps drawn this
alleged grayzone-style fire
because of his vocal criticism of the
chinese government
under its president xi jinping when i
took over the chairmanship of the
foreign affairs committee in 2017 one of
the first things i was going to do
was look at the relationship with china
and i thought i was going to look at it
very much in the way of the times which
is yeah there's problems but broadly
speaking let's see how we cooperate
better
he's referring to a period which in
theory is still current
dubbed the golden era between the uk and
china
framed by a push for increased trade and
investment
and perhaps less emphasis on security
concerns
it began when david cameron was prime
minister and included a very high
profile state visit
to the uk in 2015 by president xi
it became very clear to me very quickly
that this wasn't going to work
because the way that china was behaving
even towards us
was hostile and bullying and uh
and really meant that we had to think
again about
the way that even the committee engaged
now we started to warn
very early therefore that you know china
was not playing
by the same rules as others anymore and
that this relationship was
really difficult a similar rethink was
also underway in the united states
the u.s strategy on china for at least
the past
three to four decades had been that
supporting
chinese economic development and growth
would drive
political liberalization but the china
of today
looks less and less economically or
politically liberal
what we've seen unfold is the sort of
that shift in paradigm from
one of helping the chinese economy
develop because if they develop
they'll liberalize to they're not doing
that
and so therefore what is the new
approach we should take matt turpin
is a visiting fellow specializing in u.s
policy
on the people's republic of china or prc
at the hoover institution
a u.s think tank he previously served as
director for china
on the u.s national security council
from 2018 to 2019
following 20 years in the armed forces
and that new approach is an approach of
competition
with a desire to avoid conflict um
you know understanding that that
conflict is in neither's interest
um and that that you could achieve your
outcomes through
a strategic competition as opposed to a
conflict for its part
the chinese government has denied
allegations of hostile behavior
against other states by contrast it's
accused the us
the uk and others of being the hostile
actors
saying beijing seeks dialogue not
division
this is president xi speaking virtually
in january 2021
at the annual world economic forum
with china replacing the then soviet
union
as arch enemy of the west we should
reject
the outdated cold war and zero-sum game
mentality
adhere to mutual respect and
accommodation
and enhance political trust through
strategic
communication but critics
of the chinese communist party say such
public sentiments
mask beijing's true agenda that of an
ideological struggle with the west
in which china emerges dominant i'm
afraid that the world is
is going i hope not towards decoupling
but but
i think diverging in is inevitable
um partly because our political systems
are very different
uh and any thought of political reform
in china
i think is is well off the menu for the
immediate future
charlie parton is a former british
diplomat who spent much of his career
working on china
our economic systems are increasingly
difficult as china pushes very much a
state state model
and our value systems are increasingly
different i mean just look what's
happening in xinjiang or hong kong
he's referring first to allegations by
human rights groups
of abuses described by the united states
as genocide
against weaker muslims and other
minorities in the northwestern province
of xinjiang
this includes the alleged detention in
the past few years
of more than a million people in a
network of camps
as well as reports of forced labour and
of women
being forcibly sterilized beijing denies
allegations of abuse
it describes the camps as re-education
centres
that offer vocational training to help
counter
islamist extremism and separatism
with hong kong the uk and china are at
odds
over a new security law that london sees
as a way to curb descent in its former
colony
and beijing sees as vital to maintaining
security
against this fractious backdrop a
growing number of politicians
in the uk the united states and other
western democracies
have accused china of using grey's own
tactics
to undermine their respective countries
and to bolster beijing
this includes with alleged
disinformation operations
such as official spokespeople making
unsubstantiated claims
about how the coronavirus pandemic may
have started in the united states
the chinese embassy in london said this
isn't true
in an emailed statement it said china is
not using
this information china is a victim of
this information
and is opposed to this information in
february 2021
beijing even banned bbc world from
broadcasting in the country
alleging that its reports on china
breached guidelines on truthfulness
and fairness but the move came barely a
week
after ofcom the british media watchdog
decided to ban the chinese state tv
company
cgtn from broadcasting in the uk
after establishing that it was
ultimately controlled
by the chinese communist party rather
than editorially independent
cgtn is you know a self-avowed
arm of the state and and the party i
mean it is a
media outlet whose job it is is to to
work for this
prc matt turpin again its employees are
employees of of the state and as xi
jinping has made
kind of quite clear you know he sees prc
media as
the voice of the party right and that
their primary job is to tell the party's
story well and that that that is what
their primary job is
and that that's very different than the
concept of sort of an independent
media that that allows itself
to make its own decisions and its own
editorial decisions about what it
reports on and what it does
a very live example then of a clash of
values
another concern among western
democracies is about allowing chinese
firms to be involved in elements of
their critical national infrastructure
such as communications energy or water
supplies
you might remember a dramatic diplomatic
flip-flop
in the uk in 2019 and 2020
over whether or not the government would
allow the chinese technology company
huawei
to be involved in its next generation 5g
mobile networks
the united states put huge pressure on
london to say no
insisting there could be a spying risk
such as
if the chinese government used huawei to
plant malware on the uk
systems such claims have been strongly
rejected by the chinese
government and huawei the embassy told
me
again in its statement read by producer
chris
china opposes erroneous acts of abusing
state power
and overstretching the concept of
national security to suppress
foreign companies it is hoped that other
countries will provide a fair
just and non-discriminatory environment
for chinese businesses
huawei deals with the question of
whether it's ever worked with chinese
intelligence
in a question and answer section on its
website saying
no huawei does not work with chinese
intelligence
and never has doing so would run
contrary to our commitment to our
customers
and huawei would never betray that trust
one other area that's important to
mention is a flagship policy of
president xi's
called the belton road initiative it's a
hugely ambitious
multi-billion dollar programme to build
better
sea and land links between asia africa
and europe dozens of countries have
signed up to chinese infrastructure
projects
such as ports and railways but critics
in the west view the initiative as a way
for china
to expand its reach there have also been
allegations
of what's called debt trap diplomacy
where beijing
allegedly ensnares countries by lending
them money
to build infrastructure and then gains
power over them
when they have trouble making repayments
dr
xi yin hong is director of the academic
committee
of the school of international studies
and u.s research center
of renmin university in beijing
i asked him what he thinks well this
kind of attack
and the criticism of china he has
already operated
by western governments and western media
for years
and i think trying to set the lewis
situation much more complicated
and because china of course is portion
down to load but on one hand and this is
the learning process
but is china trying to grow its
influence around the world like does
china want more people
to follow there are a lot of
exaggerations especially about
the chinese intention and practice
of expanded strategic and military
influence
along the baton road and there are a lot
of
exaggeration i think for for most of
the i guess for most of cases chinese
motivation mainly
is economic extension and
diplomacy stage what's different about
china
compared with other states like russia
and iran that the west
also accuses of hostile gray zone
activities
is that beijing is in a position of
strength as the world's second largest
economy
and a growing military power a worsening
of ties between china and the west
would have a significant impact on both
sides
ken mccallum is the director general of
mi5
the uk's security service he used this
striking phrase to describe the
challenge
in comments he made to the media in
october 2020
if the question is which country's
intelligence services caused the most
aggravation
to the uk in october 2020 the answer is
russia
if on the other hand the question is
which state
will be shaping our world across the
next decade presenting
big opportunities and big challenges for
the uk the answer is china
you might think in terms of the russian
intelligence
is providing bursts of bad weather while
china
is changing the climate a place where a
shift
is already being felt is in hong kong
pro-democracy campaigners
and some british politicians accuse
beijing
of using a range of gray zone-style
tactics
including the weaponization of
legislation
to erode the rights and freedoms of
residents in this former british colony
china denies the allegation accusing the
uk
of meddling in its internal affairs
i was in hong kong in 1997 for the
handover
and i can just remember that people were
so worried back then
um about what would happen uh once the
handover
happened um for a lot of hong kong
people it was
such a worried and anxious period for
them
i'm talking via zoom to nathan law a
pro-democracy activist from hong kong
about the 1st of july 1997 when control
of this vibrant financial hub
returned to china ending 156 years of
british rule
i was a student at the time about to
head off to japan
to study for a year but i spent some of
that summer in hong kong
and had the chance to witness this
historic event they
were stepping into the chinese
communist regime's ruling
without any like concrete protection for
their rights um
even though the chinese communist party
promised hong kong people that
they will enjoy their weight of life the
so-called socialist
lifestyle will not um replace the
the capitalist way of life in hong kong
um
the freedom will be protected by the
basic law which is
our constitution um but these are empty
words
from common people who's 27
is speaking from what he sees as bitter
experience
in january 2020 he was hoping to run for
political office in hong kong
instead 12 months later he's seeking
political asylum
in the uk after fleeing his city
following the imposition
of a new security law by beijing which
critics say
is aimed at silencing dissent china
says it's purely about improving
security
the law can be a powerful tool of
influence and intimidation in the gray
zone
experts use the term lawfare to describe
what's effectively the weaponization of
legislation
to force an opponent to act or not to
act
a certain way it's how you use the law
as a weapon
to achieve an operational objective but
also a non-military objective
and how you can use it as well to
bolster our state's legitimacy or to
weaken
the adversary activities or legitimacy
julie
mariano a french former air force
officer is doing a phd on the subject
she's also a research fellow at the uk
think tank
policy exchange and i think that is key
the understanding of this phenomenon
today which is actually
linking every single element of the
grazing
so how important do you think law fair
is in the gray zone like how important
oh yeah it's huge yeah everywhere like
like you say grayson it's ambiguity
so you play on existing legal gaps
legal discrepancies and legal
interpretation
and the chinese are very very good at it
they've done it since the beginning
actually
they the so the the term lawful the
short-term
uh hand warfare law plus warfare was not
created by the chinese was created
knifing in 1975
but it was for the first time used as
such
and developed a strategy in uh by the
chinese in the book called unrestricted
unrestricted warfare so you know they're
very familiar with that
that that gives you an idea of their
their mindset
she's talking about a book that came out
in 1999
on military strategy by two colonels in
china's people's liberation army
or pla as the title might suggest
it explores how warfare isn't restricted
to a conventional military battlefield
but can be fought in many other ways
such as through trade or legal tools
julie claims an example of china using
lawfare
is the passing of the new national
security legislation for hong kong
in 2020 despite warnings from the uk
that it violated an agreement between
the two countries
to guarantee the rights and freedoms of
hong kong residents
for 50 years following the handover
nathan agrees well it's so clear that
after the implementation of the national
security law
there is a sense of terror and politics
of fear
in hong kong for example there are
people being arrested
just because they have chant certain
slogan they have displayed
certain flags that um resemble the
movement
and it's definitely like setting up
examples and
threatening people from expressing their
political point of view
so we could see that um the way
people acting in their in their own life
has been
changed and um
it really like strained
the whole pacific society but beijing
insists the legislation was urgently
needed
to protect hong kong from the threats of
secession
subversion and foreign interference the
chinese embassy again
in its statement voiced by producer
chris
hong kong residents have enjoyed
unprecedented rights and freedom
what the british side should do is to
discard its colonial mentality
stop applying double standards and
respect the basic principle
of non-interference in other countries
internal affairs
in international relations nathan says
what he describes as his political
awakening
happened when he was in his late teens
while at university in 2014
he and a friend joshua wong a fellow
high profile activist
emerged as leading figures in what
became known as the umbrella movement
under the skyscrapers songs passion
and extraordinary numbers have brought
asia's financial hub to a halt
their chance call for the chinese
appointed leader here to resign
but there's no anger no violence it
feels like every student in hong kong is
side by side
each fighting for the right to vote they
held
weeks of protests using umbrellas as a
symbol of peaceful descent
against what they saw as increasing
control over hong kong
from mainland china nathan helped to
found
a new political party that sought the
right to self-determination
something that's vehemently opposed by
beijing
he stood in elections in 2016 and won a
seat
in hong kong's legislative council
though he ended up being disqualified
after a court ruled that he and three
other pro-democracy lawmakers
had failed to take their oath of office
which is ultimately an
oath to china sincerely the following
year
nathan was arrested and jailed for his
protest activities
can you just talk what it was like when
you were in in jail
what was that experience like i spent um
two months and around two months and a
half there
it wasn't a long jail time but i
could definitely taste a feeling of um
being like the deprivation of freedom
and um the way that they want to
neutralize your political edge by
putting
you in jail and separating you from your
friends and families
so i think for me um i'm lucky enough
that they did not put any torture
or or physical abuse on me when i was in
jail
but for me it was a learning lesson that
i have to navigate
a pathway of being calm and peaceful
even though i
have to face such um atrocity
from the government he then left hong
kong to study for a masters at yale
university in the united states
it was around this time that he found
himself the focus
of what he alleges was a major
disinformation campaign
the chinese government launched a huge
smearing campaign on me
accusing me of um like concluding with
cia colluding with the u.s government
to subvert hong kong to suffer
china and uh posting me on
weight ball on all the major social
media accounts
fabricating my personal story and
accusing me of a trader and things like
that and
and possibly encouraging people to
harass me
weibo is the chinese equivalent of the
social media site twitter
so i actually received um quite a lot of
death
threats online and actually report to
local authority when i was
at yale and uh the police force
investigated and luckily none of them
came in
reality and can you just describe how it
felt
to be on the receiving end of that kind
of smear
well i was of course overwhelming um we
were talking about
i was like the fourth fifth sixth
most discussed topic in the whole
internet world
in that period of time in china that was
a massive amount of traffic um so
that that was quite an incredible
smearing campaign because um
i was put into example of them in their
narrative
as some hostile foreign forces
uh subverting hong kong and china
by introducing young agents i indeed
have to fight back
because that that's not true what's the
truth
well the truth is as most of the other
hong kong people we fight for democracy
because we love
our homeland and i've not received any
sort of fundings not
trained by a cia not shrinked by sale
doesn't have any military background
nathan described other much harder to
prove grayzone methods
he alleges china uses to exert control
over hong kong and more widely this
includes something called
elite capture the alleged targeting of
senior individuals in areas like
business
politics and academia so that they
wittingly
or unwittingly are encouraged to support
the chinese government
and its agenda nathan accuses the united
front work department
known as the united front for short of
involvement in gray zone activities
it's an organ of the chinese state
charged with winning hearts and minds at
home and abroad
but is viewed by critics as a shadowy
tool of influence
basically the united front strategy is
that
you isolate the main enemy and then
those that are lesser enemies or or you
try and move other people
from that status of enmity to neutrality
and from neutrality
to on your side charlie parton has
written a lot on the topic
he claims this strategy works
domestically as well as overseas
where he says the us is seen as the main
enemy
and the aim is to influence other
countries including the uk
to be either neutral or more in line
with china
and in in order to do that it
operates in the first place through
chinese citizens abroad its own citizens
abroad
or chinese of ethnic um background
uh it tries to go to go through them
which puts a lot of pressure on them
uh which again is unfair
it attempts to ensure that our
politicians
uh adopt policies that are uh
in line with chinese interests it
attempts to
ensure that our think tanks and our
academics don't discuss subjects
which are uh the ones which the chinese
government doesn't want us to talk about
like tibet
like hong kong like xinjiang et cetera
it attempts to um ensure that
um our businesses put pressure on on the
government
uh and operate in chinese interests um
the whole gamut of
ensuring that that um the world is
um aligned with with chinese interests
and um there's a sort of division i
think between
influence and interference i mean
influence in
it is another expression for that might
be public diplomacy i think that's what
everybody does
um what is not acceptable is
interference and that tends to be
covert coercive or corrupting
all of these allegations are strongly
rejected by the chinese embassy in
london
china attaches great importance to
promoting normal business
political and academic interactions with
the world
and welcomes the role of overseas
chinese nationals including students
as a bridge linking china with the rest
of the world
promoting relations and enhancing mutual
understanding and friendship
china's conduct is above board and
beyond reproach
china never interferes in the internal
affairs of other countries
or exports its own ideology or social
system
china does not threaten anyone but like
all countries in the world
china always asks resolutely to
safeguard its lawful rights which is
perfectly understandable and should be
respected
i raised the issue with china's then
ambassador to the uk
liu xiaoming during a press conference
he gave in july 2020
you said that the uk that china does not
interfere
with uk affairs and yet some people
would disagree with that and say that
china is actually conducting sort of
subversive activities trying to
influence um elements of uk politicians
and
academia and even business to further
its in its influence and interests how
do you respond to that
i would uh i totally reject
any acquisition interference in
uk's internal affairs i've been
ambassador
here for uh more than 10 years
i never come across any incident that
would have been
excused by uk government by any
you know uh institutions with a hard
evidence of china's interference into uk
things and affairs
if you have evidence please show me but
do not make this information
false acquisition against china nathan
returned to hong kong at the start of
2020
with plans to run again in elections for
the legislative council
instead he ran into legal peril with the
implementation of the national security
law
at the end of june i felt
an immense need to preserve my voice
and to speak free from the threat of the
law
so i decided to flee he's carrying on
his pro-democracy campaign from the uk
but has decided to cut all ties with his
family and friends in hong kong
because he doesn't want them to risk
breaking the new security
law simply by being in touch with him of
course
you always feel unsafe um
we're talking about the largest
authoritarian regime
in the world and the most sophisticated
um
surveillance um autocracies that we have
and um they have so many tools to
persecute or hunt down to people that
they don't like
and on the other hand there are enormous
pressure for me
that i wanted to do do more and more for
my fellows in hong kong because they are
really
facing an imminent threat and dangerous
people already in jail and there are
plenty of them
waiting to be sentenced and possibly
going to jail
also so um that is a huge amount of
pressure that i
am expecting from myself and um
it's it's not fun at all
being out of the place that you love so
i guess
that there are many
many things that that we carry
um even though we leave hong kong
and i really do hope that
every bit of actions that i'm taking now
can help and can pave the way for me
for my way back to hong kong asked about
nathan's case
the chinese embassy in london said hong
kong
acts under the rule of law
but the crackdown on pro-democracy
protesters in hong kong
is seen by many china watchers as a sign
of beijing's growing confidence on the
world stage
and it's fueled speculation about the
fate of another problem territory
the democratically governed island of
taiwan
freddie lim is lead vocalist in a
taiwanese heavy metal band
called chasonic he's also
a politician who supports independence
for his island of 23 million people
[Music]
i i think most of the people knows that
uh china send their
warships and uh fighter jets to harass
taiwan uh i think this kind of
harassment
that china down to taiwan has been like
for 20 or 30 years so it's it's kind of
taiwanese kind of uh in one hand we get
used to that
in the other hand we are always be very
cautious about that but something that
i think the world realized or even
taiwanese realized
in recent years is that china also
infiltrate
taiwan with other measures
like they spread this information they
put their hands in our local communities
he made similar allegations of
interference in taiwan by the chinese
government and its supporters
as nathan did about hong kong but while
hong kong is internationally recognised
as being part of china
taiwan's status is much greater beijing
officially claims the territory as its
own
and ensures it remains diplomatically
isolated from other countries
but taiwan's democratically elected
president psying wen
says the island is an independent
country
it's been an unresolved dispute since
1949
unification by force remains a
possibility
though that could draw in the united
states
it's why taiwan is one of the most
sensitive issues
in u.s china relations that is
potentially a very dangerous flash point
and it's a more dangerous flash point
today than it was two or three years ago
alexander downer was australia's foreign
minister
between 1996 and 2007.
going back to before xi jinping's time i
would have said well
um they they still aspire to
reunite the mainland and taiwan and
i had hoped that that would happen
through peaceful means
through a process of negotiation and
through through the evolution of time
the convergence of the political
systems in taiwan and in beijing but
actually
in the last few years you've seen the
exact reverse happen
they have started to diverge and there
are two aspects to that
one is that beijing has taken up
a much more hostile stance towards
taiwan
but secondly it does go to hong kong i
mean
they used to argue in beijing even
including to me
that look what we've done with hong kong
with the one country two systems formula
it's worked well there
life just continues to continue in hong
kong as it always did
um it's not perfectly democratic
according to your standards but then it
wasn't when the british ruled hong kong
which is true so taiwan
can learn from the hong kong experience
of the success of one country two
systems
but of course now taiwan can learn from
the experience of hong kong
which is that beijing introduces a
national security law
and exercises control over security
um over the lives of people in hong kong
um and they would do the same in taiwan
and do you think it could become like a
military conflict
could yeah i mean you could imagine a
scenario where that could happen
i think there's there's a risk of that
they're probably not strong enough
militarily
to do it without paying a terrible price
because it would uh
potentially draw in the united states
and the united states
allies into the conflict so it could
become pretty nasty
for china or everyone but including for
china
it could make the fate of taiwan a
litmus
test for which way this whole global
contest of values might go
between democratic states and more
authoritarian ones
i ask a man called puma shen who's an
assistant professor
at national taipei university whether he
thinks
grey's own tensions over his territory
might erupt
into armed conflict living in taiwan
does it feel do you feel on the front
line of
potentially something much much more
dangerous
um i mean because people in taiwan are
kind of used to that
so that's why like even like every year
that we have we got
that kind of rumor or maybe some of them
are real news
people are kind of used to it and it all
happens in
always in april and october
why because uh because it's the best
time to
attack taiwan the best time to attack
because of the weather yeah
because of the weather yeah yeah so
we're kind of used to it
like every april every october we're
going to receive this kind of
information
what do you think do you think that
taiwan
can resist and can defend its democracy
or do you think that
eventually china will succeed and
will bring taiwan fully back within
the chinese system yeah i think with the
effort of
civil society i think we could defend
our
democracy it shouldn't be a surprise
though
that an increasingly confident china
might seek to challenge
or gain more influence over a framework
of global rules and institutions
developed following the end of the
second world war
that covers areas like universal human
rights
beijing will surely be aware that what
is known
as the rules-based international system
is designed
to bolster democratic governments and
weaken
authoritarian ones that's what that
system was meant to do is meant to
advantage those systems and disadvantage
authoritarians and and isolate them
right
with the hopes that they would
eventually see the light and kind of
grant those kinds of rights to their
citizens matt turpin
from the hoover institution perhaps
counterintuitively from a western
perspective
draws an analogy with a moment in the
1997
spy comedy austin powers when arch
villain
dr evil is in group counseling with his
son
scott he says to think of dr evil as the
west
and scott as the chinese communist party
the late carrie fisher of course is the
therapist
and and scott the son is is asked so
what what bothers you and he says
something to the effect of you know i
think
i think my father's trying to kill me
and uh
you know carrie fisher's character you
laughed no no one's trying to you
you know we may say we're they're trying
to kill us but but no one's trying to
kill you
and then dr evil's character sort of
steps in and says no the boy is actually
quite quite right i am trying to kill
him i mean you know
this is what we're trying to do is
undermine
authoritarian regimes i mean it is not
something that we want to see go on now
we don't want
war um we'd love to see them transition
from
you know whether it's a what we saw in
south korea moving away from
an authoritarian sort of military rule
to a fully functioning democracy and
then the the explosion of prosperity
that happened after that or
or the same thing in taiwan in which we
moved away from an authoritarian regime
into something that
that looked very much like i mean a
fully functioning
model democracy uh and which just then
had
enormous prosperity for its citizens
right and so
that that idea is sort of i think at the
fundamental level of what we'd want
to see and so it i think it creates this
dilemma
uh for the prc in which uh to continue
to have
a system that sort of respects
individual rights
threatens their existence and that sets
us up for
rivalry and competition that is likely
to continue
um and and the sooner we kind of kind of
understand those dynamics
probably the better off we will be to
make other decisions
it's a contest that's playing out right
now
in the gray zone regardless of whether
or not
leaders on either side want to admit it
and it has the potential to affect
everyone while tensions between
china and the united states are very
much still contained
and neither side wants to see an
escalation
what does happen when the gray zone
becomes a war zone
if the uk was subjected to about two
weeks of
missile attacks removing power water
telecoms
cyber attacks that amplify that and add
new harm and social media messaging
telling them that
this is only going to get worse then
we would quickly find that our will to
resist was depleted
and if you did that not a single enemy
boot or plane or ship has
come into your territory but that's next
time
as we continue into the gray zone into
the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from sophia
mcbride and michael greenfield
and in taiwan may chindin and narrated
by me
debra haynes the head of sky news radio
is dave terrace
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts